Hi, I'm Greg Rosenberg, user
experience lead for the AdWords
platform.
I'm here to show you another
side of Google design,
one perhaps you're unaware
of-- designing our advertising
products, many of which
are listed right here.
Specifically, I'm going to tell
you about designing AdWords,
our flagship product
used by customers
who create ads on Google search
results-- those results you see
marked with the yellow orange
Ad tag in front of them.
These customers can be small
businesses like your corner
grocer, or a large
advertising agency that
manages online advertising
campaigns for big spend brands.
Like all design work at Google,
this is fun and exciting work.
However, it's truly unique
as it has the biggest
impact to businesses
and the biggest
impact imaginable on Google.
Advertising revenue is our
primary revenue source.
I'm here to show you how
critical fast, intuitive,
and beautiful are when
literally billions of dollars
are on the line and the
resulting challenge that
creates for the designers
that create these products.
OK, so imagine you're a
designer working on AdWords.
Every design decision
you make could
have a huge impact on
the customer's business
and that customer feedback works
back into the product's design.
Big pressure?
Yeah, sure.
But also a really big reward.
Let me tell you about
our challenges and goals.
We deal with tons of
data coming in from lots
of different backend systems and
factor them into our designs.
Let me show you an example.
This is our simple and elegant
alert system in AdWords.
We have a red bar that
goes across the top
for critical alerts, like
an expired credit card,
or in this case having to
review terms and conditions.
And we also have this simple
menu for less critical alerts.
Clean and simple.
This all looks really
straightforward, right.
But it's not.
By digging deeper, you can
see by looking at this diagram
that this really
simple you UI actually
pulls in data from lots
of different sources.
And a lot of logic has to
be applied to figure out
the right alert to serve at the
right time to our customers.
Our designers not only
have to figure out
what the UI looks like, but
have to figure out in what order
to show things,
how much to show,
and what to show and
exactly at what time
depending on the user's context.
Our job is also to make
the complex and powerful
into something really
simple and intuitive.
This is the keyword
set-up screen in AdWords.
This is one of the
screens customers
go through when setting up
AdWords for the first time.
Keywords are either
single or a combination
of words that trigger the
customers ads to appear
on Google search based on
the query that was entered.
OK, for example, if I own
a music equipment store
and I create an ad for it with
the keyword, buy a drum set,
my ad will appear
on Google search
when someone googles
"buy drum set."
Setting up keywords is one of
the critical aspects of AdWords
for customers to do effectively
so they get the most out of it.
Our old keyword entry
screen, shown here,
wasn't as intuitive.
It assumed a lot of
existing knowledge
on the customer's part.
It was cluttered.
And as I mentioned, it
was pretty unintuitive.
Our new one here is much
cleaner and inviting.
It gives the customer
an automatically added
set of suggested keywords that
would work best, including
search popularity for each
keyword, a cleaner way
to add their own
keywords, and a widget
that tells the customer
what their reach will
be for the keywords
they've entered.
We let the data become
the UI, and get the UI,
et cetera out of the way.
We recently redesigned AdWords.
This is the before.
As you can see in this
design, a lot of the screen
is taken up by this big
green bar at the top.
There's a white
header above that.
There's additional
links on the top right.
And generally, the user
interface is lacking polish.
In the new design,
or after, we've
consolidated the top two
header bars into one,
updated the visual design style
to match the general Google
style-- so the gray top
toolbar, red buttons.
By bringing in these
changes, customers
can focus more on
their data and less
on the controls and widgets
that get them to their data.
This is in Google's DNA.
You see it every day on our
famous and simple homepage.
And that design
philosophy is also
being reflected in our
advertising products.
What have we learned as a team?
We've learned that
beauty and design
quality of our
advertising products
not only improves them
aesthetically, but makes
advertisers more effective.
Specifically, refined
design gives advertisers
confidence in the product with
a variety of design improvements
that have come to AdWords
both large, like the redesign
I showed you, and
feature focused changes,
like the alert system
and keyword entry system.
We've seen our customers
more engaged with the product
and we receive positive
feedback that they feel better
about the experience of AdWords
meeting their advertising
needs.
With our recent redesign, we've
also received a lot of feedback
that the product was faster.
But no performance
changes were made.
It was all design.
This is the power clean
and simple design can have.
Clean, well-designed
products feel faster.
Don't overwhelm customers
with every possible option.
The alert system I showed
is a great example of this.
We used to show customers
all alerts all the time just
stacked on top of each
other, burying data
that they couldn't
see without scrolling.
We did this because we were
concerned customers wouldn't
find alerts if we
didn't expose them.
We've found with a cleaner
design and some alerts even
hidden behind a menu that
customers are not only
finding them better, but acting
on them more than ever before.
Interested in learning
more about being
a designer at Google?
Check out our Google
by Design site.
And for more information about
AdWords and other advertising
programs, check out
our Google Ads site.
Thanks for watching.